all right guys so what I'm holding here
in front of me is the core structure of
a V Cube six if you have seen my review
on the V Cube six and seven and I do
recommend that you watch it if you plan
on buying a V Cube six or seven then
you'll know that the center piece is on
the V Cube six do tend to pop out when
you are speed solving so basically that
just happened to me before and a bunch
of pieces popped out so i dismantle the
entire cube to take a look at the
internal structure and to learn how to
put it back together but also because
you can't just start putting pieces back
without knowing where they go because at
the end when you solve it it will
basically be insolvable and you'll have
to take it apart anyway so as you can
see the core structure is not unlike the
core structure of a regular rubik's cube
3x3 you can see that it has an access
piece and attached to this axis piece r6
Center supports you'll also see that
there is some sort of spherical support
that goes around between these these
Center supports so the V Cube six is
basically composed here we have 48 edge
pieces and that's basically four you can
call the modern oh you can call them
quadruplets
but that's 48 edge pieces total that's
12 sets of edge pieces you'll also have
these what I call wedge pieces that
basically go in between these Center
supports so there are 12 of those in
total I have eight here and the other
four are in here in between those wedge
pieces and the center supports go what I
like to these pieces go in between them
there what I like to call clamp pieces
or interlocking pieces and there are
basically 48 of those there's 24 sets of
them
you also have of course eight corner
pieces on any cube no matter how big it
is and then the center pieces which
basically are the majority of the cube
there are 96 of them in total so there's
16 pieces per Center and there are six
centers
so if you take a look at the math we
have 12 wedge pieces 48 edge pieces 12
times 4 we have 8 corners 96 center
pieces 16 times 6 and you also have 48
of the clamp or interlocking pieces you
have 2 times 24 which makes 48 so if you
add this up you're going to get 212
pieces in total so the entire v-cube is
212 pieces the v-cube 6 is 212 I can
only imagine how many pieces the the
v-cube 7 is I'm not planning on taking
that apart anytime soon I would like to
put a video up on how to put your v-cube
6 back together however I believe that
it probably would take me a long time
and I don't even know I'd have to break
it into parts so if you do you know if
you would like some help I would
probably be able to help you
basically what you want to get is you
want to get the core to look something
like this then what you're going to do
is you're going to take the center
pieces of any one that you choose you
could basically do any one but you have
to remember to put them back with their
proper color pairs you can't just put
them anywhere so you would basically put
the center pieces on and then you're
going to put the edge pieces around that
the corner pieces and then you're going
to build it up it's a little bit
complicated but I have figured out how
to do it I basically while I was
dismantling it you basically just
remember where the pieces have to go so
yeah I really don't know if I'm going to
put a video up on how to do that but
basically these are the entire pieces
these are the set of pieces that compose
the v-cube 6 all right guys on second
thought since the cube is already
dismantled I am going to go over the
initial steps of how to get your V Cube
6 reassembled what you first want to do
is to put the pieces into groups or sets
as I have here you want to group all of
the edge pieces together so that there
are four of them that match or are
complementary to
each other as you can see there are
basically outer edge pieces and there's
two inner edge pieces and they all
interlock together so you can basically
just set them up like that the wedge
pieces you should have twelve of them
you can group them together as far as
the clamp or interlocking pieces are
concerned there are two different types
there is one that has a bit of a lip
here a little ledge that is longer and
this is a bigger piece than the smaller
one
which fits into it and as you can see
it's a little bit smaller and the lip is
not as large the the overhang so you
want to group those together in two sets
you could put all eight corners together
and you can basically just group these
centerpieces in colors and the one on
the bottom which I'm going to start with
black you can basically group them so
that they are already set up in the
positions that they're going to go in so
we have the corner centerpiece we have
eight edge Center pieces so you can put
them like that we have the middle Center
pieces there are four of these and
there's also the four corner Center
pieces as I said before so you can group
those together like that and then what
you want to do is we're going to
basically construct this spherical
support here I have three of these
already in I'm going to show you how to
put the remaining one in and you should
be able to get the other three so let's
go on to explain how to do that alright
guys the first thing you want to do is
to grab a set of the interlocking clamp
pieces those are the little t-shaped
pieces that I have here there is a
bigger one and there is a smaller one
you're going to take the bigger one and
you're going to hold it so that it looks
like a chair almost with one ledge
facing one direction then going to take
the smaller one and hold the ledge
facing the same direction and sit it on
top of it like that you'll notice that
this smaller piece has a sort of notch
on front what you're then going to do is
you're going to hold these two together
they do not lock together so you're
going to have to hold them going to take
the
or and you're going to basically just
rest it so that that knotch fits into
the little groove here on the center
support what you're then going to do is
going to take a wedge piece and you're
going to slide it in like that basically
so we're going to have to basically put
it in like this and you're going to want
to snap it in sort of like you do with
the edge pieces of a 3x3 okay so now
that is snapped in as you can see what
you then want to do is to grab another
set of the interlocking pieces so you're
going to take the big one and put the
small one on top of it so that the
ledges are facing the same direction
you're going to hold it then what you're
then going to do is there is another
groove here and there's a groove here
that fits into that little groove so
you're going to basically you want to
hold the ledges facing this way inwards
and then you're basically just going to
put it in like that
and you're going to snap it so you
basically have the pieces here here and
the wedge in the middle so that's
basically how to construct the core it
should be pretty pretty tight it
shouldn't come apart so you want to have
one two three four sets of those